[Música]
boa tarde tudo bem
obrigado pela presença e obrigado pelo
convite uma honra estar aqui
vamos falar sobre dinheiro hoje mas
antes eu queria contar como tudo começou
esse sou eu na barriga da minha mãe ela
vai me matar de saber que eu peguei essa
foto sem avisá-la aqui sou eu chegando
em casa pela primeira vez saindo da
maternidade meus pais minha volta atrás
e minha madrinha e esse sou eu
com quatro anos de idade fantasiado de
super man
eu sempre desde pequeno sempre gostei de
fazer coisas impossíveis eu passava o
dia inteiro fantasiado de super homem
correndo pela casa achando que tá voando
e eu não imaginei que a minha missão de
vida seria algo tão desafiador quanto
falar sobre dinheiro principalmente no
ted 18 minutos
normalmente essa palestra durou mais ou
menos uma hora e meia meu desafio foi
conseguir colocá lo em 18 minutos
esse sou eu sempre fui muito tímido em
2003 numa das primeiras palestras eu fiz
administração de empresas e sempre meu
super poder como o super herói sempre
foi falar muito bem de números usando
analogias traduzindo os números finanças
para as pessoas de uma forma mais branda
de uma forma mais tranquila e foi
natural virar referência entre as
pessoas que estavam ao meu redor e via a
palestrante e nas minhas andanças pelo
brasil eu conheci uma pessoa que hoje é
muito conhecida muito influente no
mercado financeiro brasileiro que é o
guilherme benchimol fundador da xp
investimentos
só que quando eu conheci encontrei com
ele em 2003 ele era um total
desconhecido não tinha dinheiro nenhum
tinha um sonho grande tão quebrado
quanto na época em 2003
aí que não está reconhecendo ele amplia
foto ele ali dando palestras também
comida em porto alegre e ele me fez um
convite
ele me chamou pra falar sobre dinheiro e
mudar a vida das pessoas e eu menino de
quatro anos que queria ser superman e
voar para cá sem dinheiro falar sobre
dinheiro para as pessoas
vamos ver no que vai dar deu certo eu me
tornei sócio dele
até hoje a gente fala sobre dinheiro e
tenta mudar a vida dos brasileiros com
relação a investimentos nesses anos
todos eu percebi que dinheiro é muito
emocional ele está mais na cabeça das
pessoas do que no bolso e várias escolas
de análise é é acadêmicos falam sobre as
finanças comportamentais o quanto as
pessoas se envolvem emocionalmente com
dinheiro até o ponto de um daniel
kahneman psicólogo ganhar o prêmio nobel
de economia em 2002
é curioso perceber isso e eu percebi que
a cada 10 pessoas apenas uma ou duas
tinham afinidade com números elas
entendiam números e eu precisava falar
com a maioria não com a minoria
então eu tive que mudar a abordagem e
tenta entender como as pessoas iriam
compreender a forma de falar sobre
números
o primeiro insight que eu tive foi
questionar quais são os profissionais
que nos atendem um dia a dia
nós buscamos ajuda de vários
profissionais a gente vai ao médico a
gente sente dor a gente leva o nosso
carro o mecânico no carro quebra a gente
vai lá com um advogado quando nós temos
um problema na justiça mas quando é que
nós buscamos um profissional para cuidar
do nosso dinheiro as pessoas não
procuram era justamente não procura por
elas confundem finanças pessoais
orçamento doméstico com cuidar do
dinheiro elas acham que pelo simples
fato de guardarem dinheiro e aplicar
início numa poupança elas estão cuidando
do dinheiro eu posso fazer uma analogia
que mostra um seguinte exemplo uma
pessoa deixa de levar o carro dela ao
mecânico trocar o óleo pelo simples fato
de lavar o carro todos os dias
não faz o menor sentido isso é como se a
gente deixasse de ir ao médico fazer
exames de rotina cuidar da saúde pelo
simples fato escovarmos os dentes ou
tomar mais banhos todos os dias não tem
relação alguma então finanças pessoais
organizar suas finanças pessoais e
guardar dinheiro não é cuidar dele e as
pessoas fazem uma confusão e não
procuram profissionais
então nesse tempo todo é é tentando
entender a relação das pessoas com o
dinheiro eu percebi que a troca do
dinheiro por serviços e produtos
ele acontece de uma forma peculiar todos
procuram desconto comparam 10 estão
fazendo teste drive pesquisas interessa
se envolvem no processo
comprar fazer música bem a gente quer
sempre fazer o dinheiro render mais no
momento de comprar um bem mas porque
isso também não é feito no momento que
as pessoas trocam dinheiro por produtos
financeiros porque as pessoas não
questionam não comparam não pede
desconto pra ter mais rentabilidade
porque elas não se interessam por isso
então dessa forma nós temos que pensar
que nesses anos todos todas as desculpas
que recebi em 16 anos atendendo pessoas
no dia a dia
todas as dezenas de desculpas a gente
pode encaixar um desses dois campos no
campo do medo ou no campo da falta de
tempo mas o que nós temos - a gente tem
medo de ter o carro roubado
sim só acontece todo dia a gente tem
medo de ser assaltado também isso
acontece todos os dias
quem já viu um pirata de verdade não do
filme mas de verdade
imagina que você tenha um cdb uma
poupança no banco ontem e hoje amanhece
sem nada foi roubado tem que chamar a
polícia fazer um bombeiro processo a
empresa não isso não acontece isso nunca
aconteceu porque não acontece que nossas
instituições são fortes
elas são blindadas o nosso sistema
financeiro mais de 30 anos não teve um
caso sequer de roubo de investimentos
então se não é medo institucional do que
as pessoas têm medo
será que menos notícias futuras será que
o medo da incerteza que a gente vive no
dia a dia os últimos 15 anos
essa tela mostra os últimos 15 anos no
investimento em poupança comparado com
investimento de renda fixa o brasil não
foi tranqüilo
óbvio que não foi um caos na política um
caos na economia e as pessoas sempre
ficam com essa desculpa de que nunca se
sabe o dia de amanhã mas olhando esse
gráfico eu vejo porque as pessoas
continuam investindo na poupança linha
vermelha linha da poupança
a linha verde é a linha do investimento
num fundo de renda fixa e todas as
notícias que nos deixa angustiados no
dia a dia ele está aqui alguma só pra
vocês é relembrarem a reeleição do lula
em 2006
nós tivemos a a a grande crise em 2008
a gente teve a eleição da dilma em 2010
a reeleição dela em 14
a gente teve o impeachment 16
a gente teve a greve dos caminhoneiros
que parou o brasil 2018 e agora eleição
do bolsonaro será que vai dar certo
não sei não importa e veja que com todos
esses acontecimentos nada mudou o
comportamento desses investimentos
então se não é medo das incertezas
futuras e não faz sentido algum você ter
medo disso será que medo de risco porque
se a pessoa fala aqui para sair da
poupança ela precisa arriscar mais para
mudar os seus investimentos
aqui eu faço uma crítica ao mercado
financeiro ele se comunica muito mal com
vocês
ele usa palavras erradas que criam
imagens mentais erradas em vocês risco
invariavelmente quando a gente pergunta
qual desses investimentos têm mais risco
as pessoas respondem que o investimento
em ações por exemplo que a linha azul
ele vai ter mais risco o investimento
mais seguro com menor risco é
investimento poupança cdb que a linha
branca linha amarela está errado todos
têm o mesmo risco esses instrumentos têm
o mesmo risco de investimento o que muda
eo que deveria ser mudado na minha
opinião é trocar a palavra risco pela
palavra conforto e desconforto e é isso
que muda nesses investimentos
um tem mais conforto e outro tem mais
desconforto e usou uma analogia que fica
muito simples pra vocês
de um lado a gente tem que viajar de
primeira classe altamente confortável
conforto total quem estabilidade muito
baixa porque custa muito caro
do outro lado nós temos a viagem na
classe econômica que é desconforto total
e rentabilidade muito alta porque é
barato mas qual o risco dessas duas
classes
é o mesmo o instrumento é o mesmo o que
vai mudar é o conforto desconforto
dentro do avião porque se o avião caiu
as duas classes vão juntos não é mais
arriscado uma do que outro
então a percepção de que não é medo o
que faz as pessoas não mexerem com seu
dinheiro será que é falta de tempo elas
alegam que pra entender tudo isso que a
gente tava falando até então ela precisa
de tempo ela precisa se interessar
ela tem que fazer um estudo para
entender tudo o que eu quero explicar
rapidamente em três minutos mas será que
é falta de tempo
quando a gente fica doente a gente vai
ao médico a estudar medicina
esse é um problema na justiça a gente
vai a advogada vai estudar direito
a gente vai comprar um imóvel nós vamos
refazer o cálculo estrutural do
engenheiro se
rio a gente compra o imóvel será que a
falta de tempo
quantos fazem isso no final de semana
não falta tempo e as pessoas falam que
falta tempo quando na verdade o tempo
passa e passa rápido e eu sempre mostra
essa tela e perguntou quantos anos o
michael jackson morreu e ela se
surpreendem quando se dão conta de que
ele morreu há dez anos atrás
parece que foi ontem isso aconteceu
quando há 18 anos atrás de todos lembram
esse dia estava na frente da televisão
assistindo já passou 18 anos
lembro da comemoração do bebeto né ele
fazia assim com aquele bebê aquele bebê
hoje tem 25 anos 25 anos não é mais um
bebê
pegue a idade que você tem hoje
subtraindo 25 se imagine na frente da
televisão assistindo esse jogo é
impensável imaginar que você tinha
aquela idade nesse dia o que as pessoas
estão fazendo
então se não é medo e não é falta de
tempo o que impede as pessoas de falarem
sobre investimentos o que realmente
impacto o desconhecido o desconhecido
afasta as pessoas o desconhecido faz com
que a gente fique na dúvida é resgatar
essa foto dos arquivos na internet uma
foto de 1914 que mostra um hidroavião é
conhecido como o primeiro vôo comercial
de passageiros do mundo da primeira
empresa comercial do mundo essa foto
mostra o dono da companhia
o piloto e um sorriso amarelo é o
passageiro desse primeiro vôo am e aí
pergunto eu eu entraria nesse avião
nesse primeiro vôo em 1914
óbvio que não ninguém aqui entraria
porque não entramos porque é
desconhecido mas hoje a gente entra um
avião todos os dias
o que mudou nada será que a gente entra
hoje no avião com segurança porque a
gente estudou a turbina do avião
nós entendemos engenharia aeroespacial é
óbvio que não a gente entrou nos alguma
entramos no avião hoje porque é trivial
deixou de ser algo desconhecido
então quando nós passamos para a
evolução de todas as coisas que nós
usamos a adaptação do ser humano passa a
e não faz mais a mesma coisa que fazia
antigamente da mesma forma nós
precisamos nos adaptar criamos
tecnologias criamos mudanças e quando a
gente vai olhar o mercado financeiro o
mapa do mercado financeiro no mundo a
gente vê que 95% da população investe em
produtos tipicamente bancários e 5% está
investindo em produtos que não bancários
nos estados unidos a conta inversa lá
fora 98% já investem em produtos
bancários apenas 2% investem em produtos
bancários o que com a diferença
muitos dizem que o americano é rico
moderno em tecnologia primeiro mundo ea
gente atrasado será enterrado há 40 anos
atrás na década de 70 também estados
unidos tinha uma fotografia igual ao que
temos hoje ele somente 95 por cento do
dinheiro aplicado entre os bancários e
5% fora e eles evoluírem mudaram que que
fez isso mudar
eu pesquisei e encontrei muita gente não
imagina mas estados unidos também tinha
na década de 70 no final da década de 70
juros de 20% ao ano é igual o brasil
recentemente e essa taxa de juros vem
caindo ao longo dos anos e foi esse
movimento que fez as pessoas o ser
humano americano se adaptou a mais uma
coisa os juros caíram brasil a mesma
coisa
nós também temos a taxa de juros do
brasil caindo um pouco depois começou na
década de 90 e também está caindo hoje
está em 6% e vocês devem perceber isso
na conta de vocês porque os juros estão
rendendo menos né e as pessoas já estão
se incomodando veja como uma adaptação
juros reais que é juros - inflação antes
nós tínhamos oito porque tínhamos gelo
de 14 inflação de 6 sobrava 18
hoje nós temos inflação de 4 juros de 6
sobra 2 em breve muito em breve final do
ano início do ano que vem a gente vai
ter juros de 5 talvez até um pouco menos
que a inflação de 4 vai sobrar um se
antes a gente precisava de dez anos para
dobrar o capital a 8% ao ano hoje leva
35 anos e em breve vai precisar de 70
anos
então uma pessoa jovem com 25 anos antes
colocava 200 reais na poupança era fácil
em 40 anos chegaram aos 65 com um milhão
de reais
era conveniente você se aposentar com o
campeonato
ansa você tinha 1% ao mês tranquilão
só que hoje com juros baixos a adaptação
tem que acontecer porque vai precisar
ter 190 anos
para você chegar no mesmo objetivo
alguém aqui tem 150 anos 130 90 não tem
é isso a gente precisa se adaptar à
adaptação passa por entender que
conforto rentabilidade prazo não como
existem não mais
nós temos que escolher 12 desses três se
você quer conforto e rentabilidade tem
que abrir mão de prazo se você quer
conforto e prazo tem que abrir mão de
rentabilidade não dá mais para ter os
três ao mesmo tempo nós fomos mimados
por muito tempo mimados adultos mimados
por décadas de juros altos se você
pergunta às pessoas qual é a tua é o teu
perfil de investidor
todos vão falar sou conservador óbvio
que é conservador porque você não
precisa se preocupar com nada 1% ao mês
na poupança acaba quando queria mas o
que é ser conservador é aquela pessoa
que não assumir riscos e não pode perder
dinheiro
ninguém quer perder dinheiro eu não
quero perder dinheiro o investidor
agressivo é aquele que aceitar risco e
topa perder dinheiro não faz sentido
essa coisa então outra crítica ao
mercado financeiro ele usa palavras
erradas
mais uma vez meu presente para vocês o
que deve ser a cabeça de todos um
investidor conservador essa entender que
pode ser comportado né
reconhecendo que é esse é o investidor
moderado já entenderam eu vou chegar lá
e esse é agressivo é o cara que rasgar
tudo quebra está nem aí pra nada faz
sentido esse tipo de comparação e
ninguém quer ser agressivo agressivo no
nosso mundo real é algo exótico então o
correto deveria ser todos são iguais e o
que muda é que o conservador na verdade
ele tem conhecimento básico o moderado
ele tem conhecimento intermediário eo
agressivo nada mais é do que uma pessoa
que tem entendimento avançado todos são
conservadores e o que muda isso
então quando a gente fala tudo é sobre
todas essas coisas às pessoas ou mais
pra ir no médico bom é caro para um
advogado bom é k
ambos com uma pessoa boa competente para
cuidar do meu dinheiro vai ser cara não
tem dinheiro não faz sentido o juro está
caindo como é que eu vou pegar ainda e
pagar alguém imagina se alguém aparece
tem esse currículo presidente executivo
de uma gestora de fundos com mais de 20
bilhões sob administração 30 anos de
experiência entre o conselho de
administração de diversas empresas
inclusive dão breve
aos 23 anos tornou sócio de uma grande
consultoria financeira com sede em
londres foi eleito jovem líder global
pelo fórum econômico mundial
bacharel em política filosofia e
economia pela universidade de oxford e
tem 52 anos é que esse cara é caro
imagina pegar os seus 50 mil 100 mil e
contratar esse cara pra tocar o seu
dinheiro pra ele faz sentido não isso
inibe as pessoas desconhecem essa tua
mãe eo tio sam foi mais de 16 shows
sempre que pode que eu posso eu vou e o
meu sonho meu aniversário dia 27 de
novembro faz 43 anos meu sonho é vê lo
tocar no meu aniversário é possível
possível é você caro que o dedel né isso
a conta para vocês que eu já tive eles
tocando pra mim no meu aniversário
várias vezes
dessa forma essa forma mais lúdica que
eu tenho pra explicar para vocês como um
fundo de investimentos
nós vamos dividir a conta daquela
estrela aquele currículo que eu acabei
de mostrar pra vocês supercompetente
caríssimo mas eu vou dividir a conta com
mais de 80 mil pessoas dentro de um
fundo é um estádio cheio de gente
é dessa forma que eu explico pra vocês o
mercado financeiro por exemplo 50 mil
reais que você tenha aplicado um bom
fundo de investimentos que comprou 2 por
cento de taxa de administração
vai ter um custo de mil dividido por 12
vai ter 80 reais por mês
isso é menos do que o ingresso pra ver o
show do tio equivale a uma pizza com os
amigos no final de semana
então quem aplicou um bom fundo ao longo
dos últimos 20 anos 100 mil reais virão
dois milhões setecentos quem fez isso
nos juros virou 450 na poupança
virou 150 mil as pessoas que fazem
sozinhas e cuidar do seu dinheiro
ganharam 15 por cento ao ano nos últimos
20 anos quem fez com ajuda profissional
levou 24 por cento
não é porque você corre no final de
semana na praça
o bairro que você vai ser mais rápido do
que ficar não é porque você joga futebol
com os amigos no final de semana que
você vai ser melhor do que cristiano
ronaldo
não adianta dizer que sabe nadar e vai
ganhar todas essas medalhas do maior
medalhista olímpico de todos os tempos
você deve ter os primeiros entregaria
seu carro para essa pessoa
esse cara me emociona palmas para ele
obrigado